[Musik]
ja wir haben noch alles
sie lebt noch als vor einigen die
feuerwehr ruft personal raus das war der
moment der beschuldigung da war
es war schlimm wir sind einfach froh
beleben meine mutter liebt und das ist
das wichtigste
naja wir aufbauen wenn wir verlaufen
daran hat anpacken helfen und auch
trösten das gilt auch an diesem tag denn
die hochwasserkatastrophe in deutschland
hält immer noch an und damit herzlich
willkommen zu einem weiteren zdf spezial
schöner unschuldiger kann der himmel
nicht sein wie heute über
rheinland-pfalz nordrhein-westfalen ein
verstörender kontrast zu den trümmern
die geräumt und den opfern die geborgen
werden
über 150 sind es inzwischen und neue
note kommt hinzu
denn weiterer stark regen ergoss sich im
osten und jetzt im süden an den alpen
bis zu 131 liter pro quadratmeter
viel zu viel in viel zu kurzer zeit vor
allem fürs berchtesgadener land und
wieder diese schrecklichen bilder alles
voll matsch und gestein die gullys
verstopft
anwohner im berchtesgadener land räumen
heute weg was die wassermassen aus den
bergen an geröll in ihrer region
hinterlassen haben sind gut sagen wir
mal so heraus
die regenfälle in der nacht waren massiv
der pegelstand der ache steigt mit drei
meter 80 auf den höchsten jemals
gemessenen wert
marktschellenberg überflutet mehr als
500 einsatzkräfte unterwegs immer wieder
notrufe aus häusern und pkws spiel
wollen wir aus dem osten wurden aus den
orten kaum grenzregion berchtesgaden ein
paar kilometer weiter liegt österreich
die unwetterzentrale spricht die höchste
warnstufe aus das wasser der salzach ist
nicht mehr zu bändigen
murenabgänge und erdrutsche fluten
allein anwohnerin uli steht zu dieser
zeit ratlos in einem geschäft als sie
sieht was draußen passiert muss es ganz
schnell gehen
das parkchaos müssen
die alpenregion ist gebeutelt auch heute
gilt der katastrophenfall in schönau am
königssee wird eine ganze siedlung
evakuiert alles musste schnell gehen
auch für carina und josef unser nachbar
kam dann angewandt hat an der tür
geklingelt hat gesagt der ganze berg
kommt und dann haben wir schon gesehen
dass da alles runter geflossen ist da
kam dann erste bäume schlamm alles aber
mehr um unsere sachen gepackt und sind
raus sind dann kann man schon die
feuerwehr am nachmittag besuchen
ministerpräsident söder und
finanzminister scholz die betroffene
region
beide versprechen schnelle hilfe markus
söder nennt die geschehnisse einen
unglaublichen weckruf der natur
wir spüren dass sich dass der
klimawandel immer stärker auswirkt alle
die das ignorieren die die ihren
fundamental diese starke regen
ereignisse und diese unglaubliche
beschleunigung bei diesen ereignissen
die ist das was eigentlich große sorge
macht ihm schöne aber wird jetzt erst
mal aufgeräumt und ich bin live
verbunden mit dem bürgermeister der
gemeinde schönau am königssee hannes
rast wir haben es gerade gehört anwohner
sagten geschockt der ganze berg kam
runter wie kritisch sieht es zur stunde
aus ja es sind fünf großen wurden
abgegangen in schönau am königssee um
grünstein es ungefähr alle 200 meter
eine mure aktuell ist es so wir hatten
zwei siedlungen teil evakuiert eine
siedlung kann wieder zurück allerdings
den nur die erdgeschosse bewohnern so
abgehen icon seite und die obergeschosse
können bewohnt werden und die zweite
siedlung werden wir in einer stunde und
noch mal absprechen ob er die ebenfalls
freigeben
es kann sein dass weiterer regen hinzu
kommt war fast sind sehr gefasst aktuell
sieht so aus dass es zwischen 50 und 70
liter fallen sollen
aus diesem grund haben wir auch die
häuser einige häuser entlang der
königsseer ache evakuiert dort
entscheiden wären dann gegen 23 uhr hob
die markierung aufheben
die historische bob und rodelbahn ist
ebenfalls schwer beschädigt für sie als
wintersportregion muss das auch ein
dramatischer schlag sein oder
ja die rodelbahn ist was darunter
gekommen ist ein stein masken ein grill
kubikmeter große steine die ist ob stadt
eigentlich das gebäude alles zerstört
genauso schlimm ist das umliegende
gelände das in den oberligen wollte er
schließt und somit die rodelbahn auch
sichert diese straßen sind komplett
weggespült die brücke ist steht frei zum
abstürzen
seine dramatische aufeinander rodelbahn
ministerpräsident markus söder habe es
vorhin gehört macht sich in anbetracht
des klimawandels große sorgen sie
wussten dass regen kommt war ihnen klar
wie schlimm es wird wir wussten dass
regen kommt nur die vorbereitung das
sind sehr schwer
bei uns ist es besonders schlimmen schon
wochenlang oder tagelang vorher regnet
und somit ist gebirge voll ist und somit
wenn dann noch mal starkregen kommt
nimmt die natur vor allem unsere berge
nichts mehr auf und dann kommt das
wasser extrem schnell ins tal und
anschließend sehr starken er ganze nicht
gerechnet
sehen sie eine chance in anbetracht
dieser regenmengen künftig irgendetwas
anders besser zu machen mehr schutz zu
bieten
man muss sagen die muren am grünstein
die wurden vor rund 30 jahren verbaut
wir haben sie von der gemeinde immer
jährlich gepflegt die wildsau richter
halten nach pflanzungen gemacht was
notwendig war dokumentiert übersetzungen
gegeben hat dass diese ganzen
verbauungen nach 30 jahren als
heruntergekommen sind ist ist eigentlich
ein wahnsinn man muss jetzt mit geologen
wieder schauen wo es kommen jetzt machen
um künftig wieder zu schützen das heißt
dank dass sie sich die zeit genommen
haben für diese information dankeschön
drei meter sechzig da stand der pegel
beim letzten hochwasser in schuld an der
ahr kein problem für die mauern und
deiche man hatte investiert in den
hochwasserschutz am donnerstag aber
schoss das wasser auf 887 über fünf
meter mehr
dafür gibt es keinen schutz als der
bürgermeister von dieser nacht als das
wasser kam erzählt heute beim besuch der
kanzlerin und der ministerpräsidentin
muss er mit den tränen kämpfen so geht
es vielen wir sprechen gleich über das
bewältigen dieser tragödie und schon
zuvor auf einen weiteren tag der vieles
abverlangt während angela merkels
dienstwagen beinahe unbemerkt vorbei
rauscht räumen sie in schuld weiter auf
schwere bagger haben den schritt raus
geholt das ist das was von der backstube
übrig blieb in der bäckerei schlösser ob
das haus zu retten ist wird ein statiker
entscheiden unterstützung erwarten sie
jetzt von den politikern die sich heute
hier versammelt haben doch die finden
auch com worte für das unfassbare diese
flut hat auch für die menschen in not
oder wird für die menschen in scharen
hinterlassen haben
die man nie vergisst die lichts bewerten
sind und sollten hat sich von allen auf
den anderen dort in nordrhein westfalen
an der steinbachtalsperre bleibt die
lage angespannt
experten vom thw punkten weiter wasser
ab und druck vom damm zu nehmen denn der
könnte immer noch brechen in bad
münstereifel wo die touristen idylle zur
schutz lüste wurde ist am vierten tag
schon viel geschafft
ich glaube wir haben da noch helfen und
vieles ist ja auch schon gemacht wir
müssen sehen dass der müll aus der stadt
raus und das ist das wichtigste
und dass unsere trinkwasserversorgung
wieder komplett erneuert oder ins netz
kommt die meisten helfer aus den
nachbardörfern hatten selbst nur ein
bisschen wasser im keller
jetzt versuchen sie möglichst viel zu
erhalten nicht alles soll und kann auf
den müll
wir versuchen zu retten was zu retten
ist aber es ist auch eine psychologische
arbeit zu sagen wir werfen nicht alles
weg wir gucken was man überhaupt noch
behalten kann
das ist ein zusammenstehen und ich habe
selten solche solidarität erlebt
zusammen halten sich gegenseitig helfen
das ist das was den menschen in diesen
tagen kraft gibt
wir haben bei mir im studio ist er trat
sie sind arzt notfallmediziner hier aus
mainz sie waren häufig in krisen und
gebieten wie diesen pakistan
tsunamikatastrophe alles gesehen sie
betreiben auch ein arztmobil damit sind
sie unterwegs und waren eben jetzt auch
dort in diesem hochwassergebiet ihre
eindrücke was brauchen die menschen
jetzt als erstes ja als erstes wir haben
primär ein verfehlen der medikamente
ausgeteilt das fehlende asthma spray die
blutdruckmedikamente die medikamente
gegen den blutzucker aber das ist nur
vordergründig das was die menschen
brauchen wir haben viel zugehört weil
die menschen uns von ihrem leid von
ihren erlebnissen berichtet haben von
dem ertrunkenen freund von der enkelin
die einen toten im garten gefunden hat
und immer wieder eine geschichte von
einem vater und einer mutter die beide
ein kind auf den schultern hatten
versucht haben als das wasser über dem
haus war ans ufer zu schwimmen sich dann
an einem baum fest gehalten haben und
die frau konnte nicht mehr ist ertrunken
der mann konnte sich noch retten und
diese erlebnisse auch dieses gehören
hilfeschreie und wir können nicht helfen
das traumatisiert das ist das ist so
eine herausforderung jetzt und
hinzukommen es ist schnell gesagt
besteht das wasser bis zum hals wenn es
dann wirklich so ist wenn man dem tod
ins auge geblickt
was macht das mit einem menschen ja dass
das ist natürlich etwas das schwer in
worte zu fassen ist das ist ja wir hören
ja auch immer wieder ich habe angst
gehabt ich war davon überzeugt zu
sterben
auch dieses unfassbare dass dieses
wasser binnen kürzester zeit so
angestiegen ist und das ist ein
kontrollverlust man erlebt einen
kontrollverlust führt das leben für die
eigene existenz und das ist etwas was
die menschen zutiefst berührt
traumatisieren kann und dann brauchen
die menschen eine begleitung eventuell
auch eine therapie wir haben ja gesehen
momentan mit vor allem geräumt man hat
viel zu tun man hat erst mal den kopf
ganz woanders stehen ist dass die gefahr
dass man dann das trauma tatsächlich
verdrängt gar nicht wahr haben ja jetzt
die menschen übrigens auch die helfer
stehen unter einem stresspegel adrenalin
man agiert man funktioniert man
verdrängt etwas das was eigentlich
geschehen ist erst mit einer zeitlichen
latenz kommt das wieder zurück wie ein
flashback was ist da eigentlich passiert
was habe ich alles erlebt irgendwann ist
der schutt weg aber was sind denn so
indizien dass man vielleicht in einiger
zeit erst mag das hatten wir doch mehr
zugesetzt ich brauche vielleicht höfe
das kann schlafstörungen sein das können
panikattacken angststörungen sein das
können psychosomatische störungen zahlen
und eins ist noch ganz wichtig die
kinder die kinder brauchen hier eine
unterstützung die kinder werden sich
nicht melden und sagen mir geht es
schlecht sondern da braucht es
gesprächsgruppen verbrauchs eine
unterstützung man muss mit den kindern
über das erlebte reden das thema wird
uns noch lange beschäftigen der treiber
tank aber für diese information
und wenn sie spenden möchten das
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe hat ein
spendenkonto eingerichtet stichwort zdf
hochwasser deutschland die iban lautet
de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100 das können
sie auch in aller ruhe noch mal
nachlesen online unter spenden punkt
zdf.de oder im zdf text auf seite 8 190
wie die afg das mit dem klimawandel und
den anderen themen dieser zeit sieht
darum geht es jetzt gleich im anschluss
berlin direkt das sommerinterview von
talabani spricht mit parteichef jörg
motten wenn sie können
genießen sie diesen abend und einen
guten start in die woche
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]